tu
e
ma plus belle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
osisko car le grand amour et c'est vrai
contre nous c'est le grand amour
on va pas se mentir surtout de mon côté
un quoi pas de ton côté
si tout va bien contente d'être là ça va
ça fait longtemps qu'ils on avait hâte
que tu reviennes offre un très beau
décor te tutoie ouais bah ça si les
ferrière tu vois c'est rien c'est un
truc que j'ai décidée c'est un gadget en
tête voix superbe concerto à quatre
mains à quatre mains sont ligue 2 au wii
dont une autre gueule
les images seront mis mais mais mais
mais tu es mon fils et ma plus belle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma plus belle
[Musique]
pour cela
oui
peux tu me donner
[Applaudissements]
je suis jamais
te tais
[Musique]
suspension c'est ça être père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais les mains bonsoir pour la corée ne
peut pas lever la jambe ou alors que moi
je te l'a lâchement sur ton est posé
c'est vrai l'asim est ta jambe sur mon
épaule pagny pascal didier pasquette
attention à marielle qui dit obispo puce
tpm paix c'est ma raison d'être mince
indien olala essentiel est une imitation
du groupe de moi ça oui ça plutôt réussi
six mois
incroyable julien clerc julien obispo
est ce qu'on peut avoir l'huile de foie
de morue s'il vous plaît moitié moitié
moitié des boîtes à lettres au nom d'un
match
[Applaudissements]
risque
[Musique]